hello everyone and welcome back to the
capablanca saga we are back at the 1914
tournament of son Peter Burke and hotel
capablanca with the black pieces faces
Akiba Rubinstein the only player who
defeated him in the 1911 tournament of
San Sebastian so this is round three and
in round 1 cup of lanka defeated our
enemies which in round 2 it was that
very nice draw against Frank James
Marshall and now really a strong
opponent and again a keeper with the
white pieces a keeper was like a cup of
Blanca in terms of strength also a
virtuoso of the over the endgame but he
also studied opening so that made him a
very deadly opponent and this game has
been analyzed by every great player
Kasparov analyzed that I don't know if
it was in my great predecessors or some
other book but he did spoke of it a lot
and he he held a keyboard machine to a
high regard as his contribution to chess
is somewhat overlooked because he never
achieved that World Chess Championship
title but yeah a lot of players hold
Rubinstein in very high regard and well
you'll see why in this game so Akiba has
the white pieces and he opens with d4
sorry about that
we have d5 by Capablanca Knight to f3
Knight to f6 and c4 we have e 6
transposing into the Queens gambit
declined and Knight to c3 Knight B b7
and here Bishop to g5 this is all
standard queen of Queens gambit the
client stuff played even today Bishop to
e7 III and couple Blanca castles we have
looked the c1 and developing a rook rook
to e8 and Queen to c2 the idea is the
vegetable be developed the b3 and then
the pressure of the h7 pawn and also in
some lines maybe in the future if the
pawn is captured efore will be an idea
also we have c6 by capablanca
strengthening the center ends now Bishop
to d3 and as usual only now that the
light square bishop has been developed a
couple Blanca grabs the c4 pawn so he
will make use of this bishops position
to further develop on the Queen side b5
attacking the bishop Bishop to d3 and
now
the threat from whites perspective here
is 95 you want to eliminate the defender
of this defender of this defender so
basically the idea is to win dh7 point
and here Capablanca could defend it with
h6 it it is playable but then after
Bishop captures Knight captures 95
attacking the c6 pawn but should be 7
black goes into this very passive setup
that that is very unpleasant to play so
here kappa blanka plays a different line
he plays a 6 it's a pawn sacrifice but
it's a it's a really creative pawn
sacrifice it has been played before and
it has been played after but yeah well
you'll see what I mean
Rubinstein says all right 95 now the
idea is the same you cannot capture if
you captured an pawn captures eliminates
the defender of the h7 pawn and here a
couple Blanca just plays Bishop to b7 he
doesn't mind this position has been
played a year after this game in New
York Alaska plated against Hajus but not
a manual Alaska Edward Lasker his
distant relative where Queen to b6 was
played so I'm sure he knew about the
game kappa blanka vs Capablanca so he
thought Queen b6 is an improvement
controlling has a bishop to b7 but okay
that's a different game and here after
Bishop to b7
we have Knight captures on d7 Rubenstein
says all right I will take that pawn sir
Queen captures and now comes Bishop
captures on f6 Bishop captures on f6 and
now the defender of the h7 point is
eliminated
Bishop captures on h7 King to h8 and now
comes a Bishop to e4 so what's Kappa
Blanc has idea here why why did he give
up a pawn instead of playing that sort
of a passive position well now
Capablanca starts a series of trades hee
hee na Capablanca wants to trade pieces
and go into the endgame being a pawn
down and this is his idea he plays d5
and okay the captors on e5 rook captures
on e5 and Rubenstein castles his king is
now very safe and until Kappa manga
places c5 he doesn't really have any
compensation for the pawn as this Bishop
is hemmed in and we
not really doing anything so first Queen
to e7 pressuring the bishop here and
also and I support the c5 if sea-fog
will ever be played the Queen must
remain on the seventh rank to keep an
eye on the bishop on b7 rush up to f3
and now c5 is a bit too soon if you play
c5 then you get Bishop captures Queen
captures and Roxy to d1 and the white is
white is doing just fine if you try
something like group g5 to create some
sort of checkmating ideas then
Rubinstein can very very nicely defend
with 94 attacks the rook blocks the
Queen rook g6 and okay the knight is
pinned the knight cannot move although
you can always move it to geez g3 now
the problem but white can play actively
Ruby 6 now we can have Rob d8 rogue d1
doubling up captures captures and well
yeah after c4 white would have white
would have a very nice game f3 defending
the knight and also a blocking blocking
the Queen here so now even the knight
can move and it's just a pawn up for
white without any serious compensation
for capablanca but there is always
compensation the bishop is very strong
although not the knight can even capture
it but there is this three-to-two
advantage on the Queen side and this is
couple bonkers idea but not yet with the
c5 move first rook to c5 pinning the
night the idea is before to win the
piece so with a queen to e2 and now
kappa blanka goes into further exchanges
while still being a pawn down Bishop
captures and c3 rook captures rook
captures pawn captures and down rook to
d8 taking control of the the open D file
and the Rubenstein says yes sure no
problem
nobody won I will counter your rook and
I don't mind trading down as I end up
upon we have a rook captures Queen
captures and now again coupled monk I
still down upon and he still has this a
funny Bishop here until he plays c5 his
position is just weird
but c5 here still doesn't work because
you lose a pawn captures captures now
queen h5 check well we knew the c5 pawn
after the King moves so a Rubinstein
would just be up 2 points here so after
Queen to d1
first King g8 cover Blanca is preparing
c5 he doesn't allow this
when age five to come with the check we
have h4 by Rubenstein now comes c5 and
finally Bishop captures Queen captures
and now Queen to d6 attacking the c5
pawn
so here again we must ask ourselves what
is Capablanca is idea
everyone all the great players who
analyzed this game years and years after
kappa blanka was gone
said it woke up along was just defending
our worst position being down a pawn and
and he defended very actively he just
found a way to to go about it but who
knows maybe kappa blanka saw something
else here cup of Wonka's idea was b4 and
okay here Rubenstein has three options
you could capture here you could capture
here or you could say I'm a pawn I'm
just gonna block the position and try
try and do something about that in the
game Queen captures on c5 was played but
let's see what happens if C captures and
be for the seek after Sun before would
be a pretty much a force to draw because
after Queen captures Sun before Queen
captures on a six okay now you get this
Queen e1 trip okay going after the f2
pawn and now if you move the king then
you lose the punch so you have to block
with the Queen but now comes Queen
before you just make room to start
pushing your passport and it's a very
dangerous pass pawn and a very fast one
at that
Queen c1 now comes c4 and now the king
must come to help out with the defense
King you want C to check King goes to e2
and now the King cannot approach the
pawn the Queen and pawn create a wall
here but now just queen g4 you take you
go after these pawns so now you can go
you could go King D to go after the pawn
but now Queen cap sorry Queen captures
King captures on c2 Queen captures f2
Queen King b3 and now Queen captures on
h4 just leaves us with this Queen
endgame we're a cover Blanca would have
to connect at passed pawns and roguish I
would have to isolate the passed pawns
one passed pawn this isn't even a passed
pawn and this isn't so each of them
would have one passport but yeah now at
least capablanca would be connected but
about the draw endgame so he did not he
decided not to go for this after b4 pawn
captures on before like I said he played
the Queen captures on c5 but we're gonna
returned to this position after Queen
captures on c5 we have B captors on c3
Queen captures in c3 and now comes Queen
to be one check King to h2 and now Queen
captures on a two so here Rubinstein is
still up upon but Capablanca is the only
one with a with a passed pawn here so
queen c8 check King to h7 and now Queen
to f5 check
we have g6 blocking the Queen from a2 is
controlling the f7 pawn this was very
important when kappa blanka grabbed the
da to pawn Queen to f6 and now comes a
five capablanca starts pushing his
passport g4 we have a four and now comes
h5 g captures on h5 Queen to f5 check
King to g7 and now Queen to g5 check
King to h7 Queen captures on h5 with
check and King to g7 and here I was in
this position I move thirty-eight that
Rubenstein and Capablanca agreed to a
draw you just can't keep an eye on
everything you have to keep on checking
the black King couple Blanca has a very
dangerous pass pawn also Queen captures
here is a threat so white would have to
lose precious time to prevent all the
threats and it it would just not be able
to pull this for anything more than win
but this is something a lot of player a
lot of players said about Rubinstein
like Paul Karras also when he analyzed
this game this is this moment where this
Queen d6 was played and then kappa
blanka played before
this is what I wonder where they say
it's moments like these that
differentiate amazing players from
champions here you are up upon don't go
into integer ocean games just push c4
and you cannot lose this as white I mean
you can lose this but yeah you would
have a much greater chances of winning
this for example now the c5 pawn is
under attacked you have you have to go
under attack you have to go Queen a7 to
defend it and the now comes h5
after a 5 while black of course wants to
create a passport himself but now g4 we
have a 4 and now g5 and here if you its
it would be very easy to lose yourself
in this okay both of them are amazing
endgame players but it's not another
very simple position for example if you
play something like b3 here just
continue pushing then g6 is very strong
F captures H captures and now you have
to be careful because there will be some
amazing ideas your back rank is weak the
point is controlling f7 and h7 you would
have to block this but then you just
lose Queen East six check this is the
problem now because now King f8 elites
the checkmate on f7 we can just show it
and how King h8 also loses but I'll let
you pause the video and decide why King
to H eight loses I'll give you a couple
of seconds it's a nifty little idea for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
Queen winner and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show the idea is
Queen h3 check King g8 you go queen h7
check King f8 and Queen it you check
King has to go here and you win the
Queen easy peasy yeah alright so that's
the problem here and like I said it's
not all that possible for whites to to
ever lose such an endgame but okay
perhaps the Rubinstein didn't want to
risk too much okay if black doesn't put
b3 black plays King gauge 7 then it's
just g6 captures captures and after the
King moves white good white would always
have a repetition of moves if white
wished it and if not for example King J
it you could go here but doesn't really
it doesn't really do anything but I can
just go b3 and there's never any any
danger of white winning this now it
would again unwind in the draw but at
least with white you would give black
the opportunity to make a mistake you
could also make a mistake if you're not
careful but you know that's why they say
that moments like these in chess where
you can like before you can either
capture capture or push c4 and just tell
your opponent no I'm better here I'm
playing this for a win is what what you
know differentiates really amazing
players from chess champions but I am a
very nice draw between Akiba Rubinstein
whole Capablanca Capablanca mentioned
before this tournament that he was not
feeling all that great and that he he
would be very happy with winning 2nd
place in this tournament and he thought
that ok
Alaska is the world champion but
capablanca thought him and akibo
Rubinstein were the favorites in this
tournament
sure there you have it I do hope you
enjoyed the game and that you are
enjoying the capo Blanca saga so far I
would like to thank Andrew Sony Stephen
green Stefan green see along soon
Dimitri luhan's and the Marco CA for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
marco CA said that he went to visit Paul
Murphy's grave and that he's very
grateful that without my channel he
would not know about Paul Morphy and
that he would miss out on a very nice
nice conversation regarding Paul Morphy
there so I'm very happy about that and I
hope you know these kind of a kind of
little stories always make me extremely
happy so I am very happy about that as
well yeah I do hope you enjoyed it as
usual you can check - on my previous
video so you're thankful for watching
and I will see you soon hopefully with
some more interesting content checking
up on your suggestions and you know
working in the capablanca saga for the
moment checking up on Leela but also you
know what whatever comes up so thank you
all and have an excellent rest of your
Saturday